[Music]
we're gonna run all these boxes
through the mail facility we get
narcotics every day
you name it we've seen it loaded
sneakers coffee beans
radios hard drives electronic equipment
nothing surprises anymore it's like
every day you get something new
this one was a negative definitely not
narcotics
that doesn't look good and it says
sporting goods equipment and two fans
i don't see the reason to send fans they
got them everywhere
this package was coming from a source
country trinidad and tobago
and it's going to a demand country
australia
the value is very high over there for
any type of narcotic
something doesn't look right
it seems like cheap plastic but in the
image it looks too thick
the only way to really look if you don't
like the image you take a quick peek
inside
see that right there that's not supposed
to be there that's why it looks thicker
in the x-men machine
they usually glue them in and they're
not hard to
pop off try to see if we can peel back a
little bit of it
so we can see what's under it and
whatever it is it's wrapped
in aluminum foil
see it's loaded you can see that it's
white
i'll test it real quick
we should have blue with some pink above
it it's hard to see but it's there
it's positive it's cocaine
we have 806.4 grams
i can tell you what it's gonna go for
now nothing
one's pretty good guys
[Music]
you